the white house have any concerns about
this similar a similar protest happening
here in the nation's capital i think
what i would just reiterate here is that
we know that requirements work we have
not seen a disruption as it relates to
requirements to the industry where we
have seen disruptions has been related
to
these convoys and protests now everybody
can peacefully protest we fully support
that but it's important to note where
the disruption is occurring
well even at cnn they are sounding the
alarm on the convoy and the problem it
could pose for president biden
this started as a protest against that
vaccine mandate it has turned into so
much more this isn't something the bidet
administration can ignore especially
given those bridge crossings there could
be impacts to the supply train between
the united states and canada
the wall street journal editorial board
puts it this way the lesson for the
covet 19 police is that when you've lost
even canadians arguably the most
law-abiding people on the planet you've
lost the political plot
time to adopt a new strategy more
tolerant of the need to return to life
not dominated by pandemic fear and
government commands
will kane co-host of fox and friends
weekend will i want to get your initial
reaction to the idea that
this could be coming here in the way of
the white house ignoring yet another
crisis but also americans are fed up
harris i find this issue
the most fascinating thing taking place
in
the news cycle and you hear me hesitate
there because i'm trying to decide
whether or not to say the domestic news
cycle the american news cycle what i
think this is actually reflective of or
the perfect illustration of
is something taking place across western
civilization and it reveals our most
pronounced or inherent divide harris
it's not racial it's not black or white
it's not political it's not republican
or democrat it truly is to
anyone that thinks this sounds pandering
it truly is and i think it's only to
become more so obvious
the divide between the common man and
the elite what you see happening in
canada in canada
is the the the rising up of the
blue-collar worker the common man these
people are not anti-vaccines people are
not necessarily republicans these people
are not necessarily conservative these
are people that believe that individuals
should retain the right of choice and
they are
resisting a top-down approach to their
life from the elites who tell them how
they should live what they should think
what they're allowed to hear
and what they should submit to in terms
of mandates that's not limited to canada
harris that could easily come right here
to the united states take place in the
uk we see it on the streets across
europe and here's the thing harris
ask yourself this
how does it end we can discuss where
does it go does it come to united states
how does it end look at canada for for
some of that answer will if you will
they're winning i mean when i woke up
and read the headlines the last couple
of days i said well the truckers are
winning their argument and by the way
this idea that you describe um yes it's
spreading around the world but but i
sort of see america as some of the
originators of that kind of freedom
i mean
it's inherent and and who we are having
not always had it
uh one of the organizers of the freedom
convoy told fox news digital she's
downright disgusted by the liberal
media's coverage of the protest although
we showed you that little clip from cnn
saying the white house had better stop
ignoring these truckers
another trucker said it seems like
everything is a cult or an insurrection
or an assault on democracy these days i
don't understand how people fighting for
their freedom can be an assault
on democracy
you're reacting nor do i these
nor do i these truckers have been called
every insult under the sun from fringe
to far-right to hateful to a cult
and harris i think you're right that the
united states is sort of
the original
freedom-loving population but we are not
leading the way right now when it comes
to resisting top-down elite mandates
right now we're being led by canadian
truckers and so let's play this out how
does it end think about this think about
the power the common man has think about
the power these truckers have what will
justin trudeau do eventually will he
send in the military there's not enough
police there's not enough ottawa police
nor toe tuck companies and by the way it
sounds like the tow truck companies are
resisting hauling away these
trucks
right right you better have you better
have a big tow truck um so what is he
gonna do send in the military to to
break up this protest and even at that
even if he did that harris then how does
he pick up the the slack in the supply
chain will the military then deliver the
goods and services across canada these
truckers are supposed to be
doing on a daily basis this is the power
you know when you bring it back to the
united states of america we do not know
the power that we hold over the people
that would like to lure their power over
us
ultimately these elites are a minority
an extreme radical minority certainly in
their ideas but ultimately still the
united states of america the power rests
with the people
it'll be interesting to see when
american people lead the way
well look everybody has a visceral
reaction to that grandpa that great
grandpa being hauled off by the canadian
police and and you say well what is
justin trudeau going to do well if he
does too much of that
it could get really interesting because
those truckers are honking their horns
now they've been told they can't i mean
they're being silenced
you know what tammy bruce and i got into
this will and i thought of you yesterday
as she was speaking because i've heard
you make a similar point i want to get
into it now
um she made the point about the freedom
convoy protest in comparison to the
protests here in the united states just
watch and listen
i think that we saw the inkling of that
with the school board meetings and
parents yes that was the same dynamic
without trucks
where americans were saying very vocally
enough is enough and that can and will
grow and this has been inspirational for
people they're seeing it americans
truckers the supply line of course they
remain under attack i have to say we had
the great resignation we have people who
are not going back to work that might
also be interestingly a very quiet
protest that is occurring
will
yeah and you so here's what i think is
so fascinating this will take us back to
the original question you asked me this
dynamic between the average american the
average citizen of the western world and
these elites will become harris will
become undeniable do you think all those
parents in virginia that were called
domestic terrorists vote republican
probably not yet
the point is this crosses partisan
divides anybody that dares stand up to
this elite monolithic group think that
that tolerates no dissent
is called a domestic terrorist it's
called um when you're a trucker you're
called a cultist you're joe rogan and
you you advocate for bernie sanders and
you're called a propagandist and
purveyor of misinformation and your your
your voice must be silenced it's going
to become undeniable it's becoming
undeniable and and i think that um
i think we've never seen
at least in my lifetime
this type of flex from those who think
they have power against those that
actually have power
this type of flex
uh what tammy brew said about the great
resignation there's 38 million people
who quit their jobs by october of last
year she said that's the equivalency to
a silent protest that could build um
great to have your comments on that
let's get to this big backlash is the
biden administration may be looking to
place hundreds of migrants under
part-time house arrests
well i call them illegal immigrants
because they're here illegally and now
of course if they're putting them under
house arrest they're making that point
they say it's much cheaper than holding
them at detention facilities
as illegals are flooding across the
border in record numbers reuters is
reporting pilot programs will begin in
houston texas and baltimore maryland
with 100 to 200 single adults under
house arrest in each city detainees
would be required to be in their home
from 8 pm to 8 a.m with exceptions for
work and extraordinary circumstances
critics such as the arizona attorney
general mark brnovich say this is a joke
it's obvious that the biden
administration is systematically trying
to not only dismantle ice but
essentially eliminate our entire
southern border and the taxpayers hard
working middle class taxpayers are going
to subsidize this progressive left
social experiment and unfortunately it's
going to be all of us are going to pay
the cost
will talk to me about what the ag is
saying there what kind of a social
experiment experiment is this
one that they say is driven by
compassion so under this house arrest
you point out here supposedly it will
cost six to eight dollars a day to house
a migrant on house arrest versus 142
dollars a day in a detention center
these migrants apparently would be
confined to their home from 8 pm to 8
a.m makes you wonder what do they do all
day
and i think you find the answer pretty
quickly is they go out and work and live
the life that they actually came to the
united states to live but here's what's
funny about that supposedly that's
driven about compassion a more
compassionate approach to this than for
example they say the trump
administration but it's interesting who
they're compassionate toward and i think
this is inseparable from the america's
rising crime crisis
you seem to be compassionate towards
those that break the law not to for
those who suffer at those who are
breaking the law the hands of those who
are breaking the law and by the way just
like a permissive parent who constantly
meets a rule breaking child with
compassion you only are going to get
more of it you're going to get more
illegal immigration and thus you're
going to have less compassion towards
americans who lose jobs who suffer from
crimes from illegal immigrants or in the
rising crime crisis suffer higher rates
of murder who exactly is the recipient
of your compassion well and and we've
seen the busloads of adult males mostly
and some women not families being
dropped off in cities i mean this
accelerates that with legitimacy now yes
they're here illegally we're going to
house them we're only going to keep
track of them and the sleeping hours and
who knows if they're keeping court dates
they weren't keeping them before but now
you've legitimized whatever it is
they're doing and you've given them time
away from that dwelling to go to work so
you've normalized their illegal behavior
it it seems counterintuitive illegal
immigration to a nation with borders
we'll move on
will great to have you in focus today
thank you